reject Nation we are here
it's it's early it's early rejects I was
like oh I'm doing I'm not doing it anymore
we got ourselves an official trailer for
Transformers rise of the beasts I am so
excited for this movie now we got ourselves
an official trailer more than terracons more
than the Autobots you know what I'm really
excited for Anthony Ramos yes my man I'm so
excited for Anthony Ramos as a man who looks
Latino but isn't actually Latino I couldn't
be more excited for the representation that
we're getting in this movie let's go into
this trailer before we do it leave a like do it
do it for America for America and Anthony Ramos
centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden on Earth
yes yes Darkness has found us again
a better shot of air razor there
about the fate of all living things
they officially confirm you across country
Ramos and Mirage Becca Oh I thought we
were boys you want it I brought a human
here I'm nobody I ain't even seen nothing
I'm not even seeing anything right now
this is not our war Optimus we must trust
each other to protect the home we all share
uh he eats planets so like
way bigger than a planet
boy
it doesn't even matter everything you cared for
maybe there's another way to save our home the
Mayan calendar you've never faced
anything like this let them come
on
awesome we got ourselves a water
let's go
I'm sure they're over
Take the Wheel
is he controlling I mean it looked like he
was about to be enveloped in in Autobot nano
technology put some Iron Man stuff right there
he's about to have his own suit is that his
voice going yeah baby so he was actually like
controlling the Transformer I guess so I mean
that's that's what I get the the the sense from
Take the Wheel like I don't feel like it would
just you know coat him in something he has no
controllers yeah oh awesome yeah I mean Unicron
has been I believe since the I barely remember
those other movies honestly I Erica's favorite
franchise I did a reaction to the last two Michael
Bay movies it would be like I'm watching them for
the first time ever the way they should be seen
But if I'm not mistaken one of I believe it was
the last night where they they did tease Unicron
already and then the big theory has been that
Unicron is gonna be the ultimate big Baddie that
we are building to the fact that the trailer did
yeah confirm it's not only in name but visuals
as well I think is going to be very exciting
for Transformers fans all across the board to have
the big Baddie coming this way but right now let's
just focus on the immediate plot hackers you know
they're going to win in this movie they're gonna
win at the end of the day but we will build there
because I feel like this movie is going to be the
one that many of us believe is going to reset the
timeline because while this is a sequel to the
prequel but it's still a prequel to The Original
films this one's definitely gonna do something
with the timeline considering they have all of
our beasts in action here every one of them looks
really great you know like as much as we love our
Bumblebee as much as we love love or Optimus Prime
you know like we're getting all these great shots
of Primal in here we're getting all these great
shots of like Chi tour we're getting these great
shots a mirage I just want to hear Pete Davidson
talk he gets a lot of crap but you know what I
think Pete Davidson is actually funny so you know
what he's just one of those people people where
people just talk bad about them all the time yet
he is so successful and gets all the ladies for
a reason because he's really funny because he's
with your girl right now I know for some reason
people were like oh pretty but you know what
Pete Davidson he's gonna be funny in here because
he's essentially serving the role that you would
give to bumblebee to bumblebee could talk yeah
radio and clip-its if he had a popular comedian's
Personality yeah everyone looks great here you
know uh what but John and I and I feel like you
know if he if Anthony Ramos's Noah is able to get
the powers uh or able to use like some type of
nanotech to be able to Pilot himself a Transformer
that would really make it seem like okay movie is
not just some human I mean angel in the fight yeah
and I think the character is supposed to be you
know like a military technology X expert rather
than every man you know uh we did our research on
Anthony Ramos no right Noah he's gonna be the new
leader of the friend forget Optimus Prime forget
Unicron even Megatron is all about Noah moving
forward but hey I've been up all here for a human
who feels vital to this stuff I mean no shade to
Sam Witwicky but but yeah I don't know that could
be a pretty cool development and it's nice to have
a big huge you know a notable villain who isn't
going to be Megatron yeah it's nice to break from
that and yeah also to have a situation where it
feels like maybe it kind of makes some sense that
they're fighting on Earth and the Earth is related
to this in some way with the Predacons uh you know
going after the maximals and whatnot the maximals
hiding on earth like I don't know I feel like that
could even you know the earthliness of the stakes
before we go to the cybertroness of the stakes you
know in the beginning of this show they're saying
it's not our fight you know that that usual like
this is in our fight we don't need to get involved
but if they are following the Beast Wars storyline
at all it's their fight yeah it's important yeah
for sure well and you know Optimus primal being
like a direct descendant of Optimus Prime too
like both ties in Earth's involvement but also the
greater scoping involvement of you know Autobots
and Transformers of all benevolent varieties
well the uh final battle at the end where they're
fighting all the terracons because you know if
like terracons are just essentially zombie-like
Transformers and and then you have like all
these great shots of all the Transformers working
together what I do love is the visual that it's
just like Transformers they're like it's Autobots
maximals and terracons fighting each other at the
very end and it's such a glorious looking shot and
RC really getting a chance to shine here uh in in
the battle sequences as well because while like
it does have like a dark looking cinematography
especially to have the bleakness kind of reminds
me like the infinity War battle with whatever
those creatures are called you know uh there's
still a a good color pop with it with enough of
our protagonist characters here at the very end
that I think looks great yeah um they have that
dingy grimy dirtiness but then that gives you a
good opportunity to be able to well identify who
are here yeah I hope all the all the maximals get
an opportunity for their personalities to shine
you got Scourge in in the voice of Peter Dinklage
so I hope they actually utilize scores in order
for him to you know really just stand out Beyond
like hey you're another version of Megatron you
know I mean they have like these shots in the
trailer where he's like whooping bumblebees ass
but I'm wondering if bumblebee gets taken out
of battle and then it's part of the Nano it looks
like the nanotech forms to Noah no via Ramos yeah
right yeah well uh yeah I mean that's certainly
the sense I got is there's got to be it's it
either way it's nanotech equipped but also yeah
something that can create a bond a link Etc and
and maybe there's a transformer in the mix uh who
can you know mimic the shape of other Transformers
so maybe that's not an actual bumblebee getting
murked uh is that Raj the one was able to do that
is that Mirage there you go that would make a
lot of sense create Illusions and things like
that create likenesses so maybe that's a sacrifice
yeah too alrighty guys well thank you so much for
being here what did you think of this transfer
performers rise of the Beast trailer are you
excited for this film I hope you are hey leave
a like subscribe I'm gonna get this video to
y'all right now it's already been to you but
in my time of filming this I'm working on it